[00:48:32] We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
I got a bunch of these questions about the
connection, the possible connection between
Corona virus and the election in November.
Take a listen.
[00:48:46][13.8]
[00:48:48] Oh, David.
The name is Storrar, longtime follower question
for you.
If the Corona virus should keep going on until
November election time, could a Trump declare
the election, postpone, cancel and essentially
go on as president without an actual election?
[00:49:10][22.2]
[00:49:11] Not really.
So here's the thing.
First of all, Trump couldn't postpone the
election by himself.
You would need congressional support to do
it, even with congressional support.
It would be difficult to do.
Trump could say it, but that would not make
it so because Congress sets the time, place
and manner of federal elections.
But the thing is the following.
Congress would need to rewrite three U.S.
codes, subsection 7, which has the timeline
for electors, which are chosen by states to
vote in the Electoral College.
Remember when we vote in November?
Each state is saying we want our electors
to vote in this way at the nominating convention.
The electors convention that is set for December
14th.
So if lawmakers manage to delay the election,
they really couldn't delay it beyond, you
know, a few days before December 14th without
having to rewrite the Constitution itself,
which says the president can hold to office
a term of four years.
The election is happening at this place, so
on and so forth.
Now, here's the other thing that a lot of
people are worried about, which is imagine
that Trump succeeds in doing it.
Does he just remain president?
And the answer is no, because this has been
researched.
The 20th Amendment terminates each presidential
term at noon on January 20.
So even if at the federal level, at state
level, things were delayed, Trump as president
would be terminated on January 20th regardless.
Now, of course, it would all be a legal fight.
It would be unprecedented territory.
But the idea that Trump could do this to just
stay in power for some period of time seems
extraordinarily unlikely and not something
that I would I would put too much time into
worrying about.
The real question now is what's going to happen
with the primary Louisiana and Georgia already
deciding to delay primaries.
There's now a fight about whether the primaries
happening in March should even be delayed.
That is a much more present, present thing.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will actually talk about Georgia and Louisiana
postponing their primaries.
We will talk about Trump saying that he's
going to waive federal student loan interest
due to Corona virus.
And we will also talk about Trump considering
a full pardon for ex advisor Michael Flynn.
[00:51:37][145.9]
[00:51:37] We knew it would happen.
All of those stories and more on the bonus
show get access instantly by becoming a member
at Join Packman.
[00:51:45][7.9]
[189.8]